and while this is a good day for many
let us not forget that we lost one of
our own
detective colin zabal was an exemplary
detective
a son a friend a protector
hey guys pete here this will be my mayor
of east town episode 6
breakdown only one more episode after
this and we got some answers
mare's recovering but reeling over
colin's untimely death
and richard shows that he's paying
attention by bringing the right hoagies
that she told him about in her
recommendations when they first met
real quick this video will contain
spoilers if you haven't watched the
episode yet
so this is your warning and your last
chance to leave
with that out of the way let's get
started the episode was
jam-packed a lot happened it ended in a
cliffhanger but we do
tie up a lot of the side stories or at
least what felt like conclusions for
those
and then we got what is supposed to be
answers to the big mysteries
but because this is the second to last
episode
feel like there's probably more that we
haven't seen
there's probably a twist or two that
still isn't clear
and it makes you wonder if what we
learned that
billy is the killer and the father is
actually true or not
let's look at the things they did wrap
up as far as deacon mark's concerned
he gets called in after father dan goes
and talks to the police
he tells them the exact same story he
told father dan
and it seems to me that this is the end
of deacon mark's involvement it seems
like he's telling the truth and it would
feel kind of out of place next week if
we found out there was more going on
with him
he was arrested for throwing the bike in
the river but i don't think there's any
further revelations coming in his story
on a slightly happier note we did see
dawn and katie reunited
she was able to bring her home she's
with her daughter kenzie again
and though dawn does explain that she's
having a hard time adjusting which of
course she would
we do see that dawn's grateful to have
her back she apologizes to mare
and all of this did seem like the
conclusion to that part of the story as
well
at this point i don't think there's
anything else going on with the
kidnapping
in relation to what happened to aaron in
a much sadder note we saw freddie's
story come to an end as well
eagle-eyed fans who really looked
closely at the trailers
had already put together that mayor was
going to find those clothes in freddie's
house
and unfortunately she was responding to
a call from beth
who was worried about her brother
because she couldn't get into his house
and mayor discovered his body after his
od which was really sad to see
when they go to see kenny at the jail
there's an explanation for how he got
the clothing
i guess it makes sense it sets things in
motion for mayor to start looking in
digging into what happened at that
reunion and things fall into place from
there
i don't know if we should call it a
conclusion to siobhan's story
but we did get a better idea of the
tension that exists between her and her
mother
through mare's ongoing therapy we find
out exactly what happened on the day
kevin died
a neighbor called her because they saw
kevin going into the house
she assumed that this was for drug money
because that's why he always came
and she was away so she asked javon who
was close by to go over to the house and
talk to him
that meant that she was the one who was
there to find kevin hanging in the attic
this was obviously very traumatic for
her and she couldn't even speak when she
called mare on the phone
mayor rushed home had to cut him down
she says she held him
and stayed with the body until the
paramedics wrestled it away
it's pretty heavy i gotta mention it but
this is one of those highlight
performance moments
kate winslet really delivered everything
in this scene
her facial expressions in the delivery
work in a way that we're seeing how
she's processing what she's saying
and she's touching something inside that
she stayed away from
it's set up really well with colin's
death opening the door
her visiting his mother and getting
slapped and that taking her one step
closer and then we see things come to a
head when siobhan comes home wasted
later in the episode
i haven't been the biggest fan of the
siobhan storylines thus far
but not sure how far this goes beyond a
moment for mayor to understand how
not dealing with kevin's death has
affected everyone around her
but again the performance here made the
payoff work and we do see mare willing
to apologize as she's hugging her crying
daughter
if those were the most dramatic scenes
the most intense
had to be jess's encounter with dylan in
the bathtub scene it carries
after brianna called the cops and told
them that dylan wasn't in bed on the
night of aaron's murder
they interviewed him again at the
station during that he found out that he
was back at the top of the suspect list
and mayor kind of bluffed him about the
journals so after he lawyered up and got
out of there he wanted to talk to jess
about what she told the police
as far as i can tell she hadn't told him
anything at this point and she just
doesn't want to be around him
but he still wants to talk to her and
when she won't get in the car and runs
away
they chase after her it almost looks
like she's going to get away when she
finds a hiding
place but he does find her and then he
threatens her with a gun
i'll come back to that because we saw a
couple of guns in this episode
and neither one of them is a match for
the bullet that was found in the tree at
brandywine park he does point the gun
at her and tells her not to open her
mouth again or she's gonna end up
getting shot in the face just like aaron
it's intense but it's also annoyingly
vague as far as what he wants her to
keep secret
overall this scene mostly just
accomplishes showing us that dylan
is actually worse than we thought which
is saying something
adding to the intensity is the bathtub
scene we had seen carrie at work earlier
in the episode
and found out that she was working crazy
hours and also it looks like she's
staying clean as she turns down her
co-workers offer of a pick-me-up
mayor drops drew off at her place they
seem to be getting closer getting along
really well
as mayor told frank he didn't even turn
around to say goodbye he was happy to be
there
as she's giving him a bath it looks like
she's getting tired and eventually she
falls asleep
briefly when she wakes up we see him
with his head under the water
and we're just as relieved as her when
we see that he's all right he was just
playing
he just had his head under the water
he's definitely not drowned in the tub
right now i'm reading carrie's part of
the story as being exactly as it seems
she seems to be working hard she's in
recovery which is a whole different
challenge
on top of that and we see that she's
learning how difficult it's going to be
to keep doing everything she has to do
and having full custody of drew at the
same time
to me it looks like with mare making
progress
and carrie doing what she has to do
we're probably gonna see them come to
some sort of compromise where they both
keep an
active role in raising him who knows now
that faye's gone maybe she'll move in
with frank and that'll make
things easier either way it seems like
it's going in a non-tragic direction so
we'll have to wait and see what happens
the big reveal in the episode is that we
hear billy
with his own mouth to be sure say that
he killed aaron
by the time we get there it's heavily
implied that he's dj's father
he would have a motive there especially
if she was threatening to reveal that
secret
but boy does it feel a little hard to
believe based on how things played out
the first big red flag is his reaction
to jon coming to live at their father's
house
he says your life's a mess because you
couldn't keep your dick in your pants
now you clean it up this doesn't seem
like the same
person that we later see breaking down
over his guilt
about being a killer also after their
dad tells jon that he saw billy come in
covered with blood on the night aaron
died everything john does
after that kind of feels like he's
trying to manipulate things and take
advantage of the situation
when the confession comes we don't hear
the whole conversation
and depending on how you interpret it it
at least seems
possible that jon is orchestrating the
whole thing
coming into this episode billy was
losing steam as my early favorite
suspect
i was moving towards looking way more at
john alone or maybe jon
as the killer and billy as the father
i'm coming out of the episode thinking i
might have had it flipped
but still stuck on jon and a situation
where nothing that's happened with billy
really makes sense
one thing i feel certain about is that
jon is the one who comes off as sleazy
he's the one that has a history of lying
and cheating on his wife
and he just comes off as being more
capable
of doing these diabolical things
independently mare's work in the case
and she's coming to the conclusion that
billy's the father and the killer
she tracks down the jewelry store where
the locket came from
and finds out that billy bought it when
i first watched this scene i
only saw the name ross on the receipt
and thought that this might be a big
clue that it could be either one of them
but when you look closely you see that
on the bottom sheet of paper it actually
does say billy ross
mayer gets to that conclusion she calls
it into the chief he tells her to stop
wait for backup and she does the exact
opposite she actually speeds up after
she talks to him on the phone
she found out from lori where they were
at so she's on her way to where they're
fishing
and like i said none of it exactly adds
up
john goes to lori and he tells her the
story that billy's the father billy's
the killer
and that hey don't go tell mare about
this how would he ever feel confident
in his situation at this moment and
expecting his wife who he's on the outs
with
to keep this a secret from her best
friend
it doesn't add up it feels possible that
he might have went and told her that
because he knows she'll tell mare plus
when he goes to talk to billy billy says
he's ready to
confess but instead of just going and
doing that
john says why don't we go fishing first
when they go out to the truck billy
finds out that there's a gun in the
tackle box
the way i interpret this is that billy
did not bring the gun
instead he discovered that jon was
bringing one
and this has him worried about why that
would happen
when they get out john asks him for the
tackle box and he says no i got it and
he keeps it with him
after seeing that it looks like john
wasn't confident that
billy could hold up the story or that
after he confessed
something else was going to come out
that john doesn't want to get out i
could be wrong here
it's definitely possible but to me at
this point it looks like
john set everything up so that he could
get billy alone at the river
and kill him mare is arriving there
thinking that billy's the killer
and that might be setting up a situation
that jon can use to his advantage
anyway although if billy makes it out of
there alive whatever he was worried
about
whatever he was worried about getting
out or whatever made him want to bring
the gun
in the first place probably will come to
light
the final bit here is that while she's
on route jess does come in
she doesn't listen to dylan she goes and
talks to the police again
and she gives the chief this photograph
which we don't get to see
as soon as he sees that he says to get
mare on the phone and you have to
remember that mayor told him that billy
did it
which makes this feel like the
photograph doesn't back that up
it's a setup i'm not sure what to think
they put a lot of effort into making us
question what we know and what that'll
mean for the ending
and i guess that'll be fine if they
deliver a memorable finale
what's really going on with dylan is a
mystery it seems less likely that he was
just trying to burn the journals to keep
the real father a secret
because he wanted to keep dj but it's
not any clearer as to why jess was
working with him
and what happened to make her change her
mind the photo that she
kept and the chief's reaction to it make
it seem like that'll be key to solving
the case
but we're gonna have to wait until next
episode to see what it actually is
finding out the bullet in the tree came
from an old police revolver is a weird
twist
none of the guns we've seen in the show
are a match for that we've seen dylan's
kenny's dons and the one in the tackle
box and none of them are revolvers which
means that detail might just be there
for that purpose
it's hard to say there is a shot of a
gun in the trailer
and it looks like you can figure out
whose that is so i'll get into that in
my next video because at this point i
don't even know what it means
in the end we learn more about mayor we
see what she's working through
why that's been difficult and we see her
working on the case
that process putting all the attention
on the two ross brothers
setting up a situation where she's gonna
be there by herself
confronting them at the river as it
stands everything is still pointing to
jon as pulling the strings
but i can't explain why billy is
confessing or what dylan is up to with
jess
that could be just local unrelated crime
stuff but it seems a little surprising
that jess would be involved in that
obviously billy has something going on
beyond heavy drinking
he was covered in blood after all and he
looked like he had his faculties about
him enough to try to hide it from his
dad it doesn't look like he was
uninvolved but is there a possibility
that he doesn't know what happened
i mean none of the explanations i come
up with seem very solid at this point
also i don't know how this comes back to
mare and her personal journey
it's not like she overlooked these
characters as suspects
since there was no evidence connecting
them up into this point
i mean it could just be that this was
her friend's family and that this was
going on and nobody noticed it but i
still think there has to be more under
the surface
there's still a lot of little things
that feel like loose ends which there
will be some
but there's still an hour to go with
mare already there
ready to have a confrontation with the
two main suspects
i've never been keen on the ryan shot
aaron or
laurie or siobhan shot her but there is
room to tie them into the larger picture
if one of the ross brothers is dj's
father then there's at least the
possibility of more abuse inside the
family
maybe they'll go down that road maybe
it'll be about family secrets in a town
where everybody knows everybody
but they don't know the whole story i
don't know i'll have to give it some
thought
so i'll leave it there for now and in a
couple of days i'll come back i'll break
down the trailer and i'll tell you what
theories i have at that point
i'll give it a re-watch i'll see what
other people are saying about it
and see what i can come up with so let
me know in the comments what you think
how you think things are gonna end and
the biggest questions you have going
into the series finale
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon